rural South Africa this is where the ANC
draws upon most of its support the
village of in-vessel is the birthplace
of anti-apartheid icon Nelson Mandela
and its residents staunchly back the ANC
Magda Mandela is Nelson Mandela's eldest
male heir and the chief of embezzle
community he was nine years old when he
first met his grandfather who was in
prison at the time when it was apparent
to Nelson Mandela that his grandson
didn't know who he was he told a friend
to contact the young boy conversation
man vividly recalls your grandfather
says you went to visit him you had no
clue who he was and why he was in prison
the ideals he stands for and his
commitment to the struggle for
liberation of our people he's asked me
to educate you about who he is Mandela
went on to spend many years by his
grandfather's side in 2007 he honored
him by leaving his life in the city to
take up duty as the head of the 350
households of from vigil people in this
village referred to Mandela Mandela as
in OSI meaning chief and part of his
responsibilities are resolving issues in
the community like family squabbles but
in what seems like a world away from
this rural setting about a thousand
kilometers away South Africa's
Parliament and there he's referred to as
MP Mandela and the roles couldn't be
more different
as an ANC parliamentarian Mandela
loyally supports its policies and even
as criticism and resentment towards the
party among South Africans is growing he
says it sees duty to follow the party
line I'm not there on my own individual
thinking I didn't take myself to
Parliament I was nominated to Parliament
by the African National Congress and I'm
to carry out policies and ideologies of
the African National Congress and
Parliament after 23 years of dominance
the ANC appears to be losing its grip on
South African politics in local
elections last year voter discontent
over an ailing economy along with
scandal surrounding President Jacob Zuma
led to the worst election result for the
ANC since Nelson Mandela swept to power
in 1994 but Mangla Mandela suggests
critics of the ANC speak from a
privileged position a narrative the
party has been pushing a lot of people
were saying chief what are you saying
about the demonstrations and the call on
the president there's a lot of white
people that are out on the streets
protesting also I can say a the
president to step down I say I'll ask
you one question when you come out to
the streets talking about your plight as
communities in rural communities that
have no clean drinkable water to those
people come out in support of that
campaign the reality is they don't I'm
real to my people and our needs and I'm
only committed as a parliamentarian to
the needs of my people and the needs of
rural South Africans because I can tell
you that we share two different
struggles while the more well-off in the
country struggle should protect their
wealth people in communities like this
one face unemployment and poverty the
level of inequality that persists in
South African society is enormous Manta
Mandela defends the ANC by pointing out
what the party has managed to accomplish
between the period of what 1970 to 1990
there wasn't a single house built by the
apartheid regime and yet in two decades
this new a insulated government has
delivered what over six six million
houses that is an achievement mind you
you have a country that has been a
challenged and stripped for almost four
centuries and that cannot be corrected
in two decades the role of man Zaman
grandfather in ending apartheid has
inspired millions of people around the
world but as this country reflects on
how far it has come in 23 years more and
more South Africans are asking if the
party Nelson Mandela once led is what
they need for the future